[Musik]
hallo herr zwanziger ließ welt heute
gibt es ein ramadan bisher für euch und
zwar ein dass er was mich wirklich sehr
stark an meine kindheit erinnert weil es
meine oma immer zubereitet hat und zwar
ein dass er mit zwieback ich hab jetzt
auch gerade überlegt ob sie backen
markenname ist aber ich glaube es ist
keiner ich glaube zwieback nennt man
alle diese büro teilchen die zwei mal
gebacken sind zwei mal toppen jedenfalls
gibt es da marken produkte oder auch
neuen produkte und im türkischen und das
wusste ich nicht ich dachte es personen
habe ich sage ich jetzt so ein dessert
war es türken in deutschland machen aber
im türkischen gibt es nämlich auch und
weise dort diktatorische und in
deutschland nutzt man eben dass das
zwieback gepäck dafür und ja wie gesagt
meine oma hat es immer zubereitet und
deswegen ist schon so ein stück weit
kindheit und zwar ist das eine schicht
zwieback das ganze wird getränkt mit
sirup darüber kommt ein leckerer pudding
und da oben drauf noch kokosraspeln
meine oma hat immer recht klassisch
gemacht und einfach gemacht ich wette
zum bisschen verfeinern und
geschmacklich noch mal ein bisschen
hervorheben deswegen gibt es da ein paar
änderungen also für alle die das
vielleicht ganz klassisch kennen das
wird zwar auch in recht klassisches
rezept auch so ein bisschen eine wie sag
ich da gepimpte version von sally so
machen wir das und ihr braucht dafür
entweder eine glasform am besten eine
eckige denn da passen die parteien schon
am besten rein vor allem habe ich hier
zum beispiel eine form die von porsche
passiert wirklich schöne rechtwinklige
ecken also da kommt man wirklich auch im
zwieback bis an den rand oder verwendet
einfach den bug rahmen ich denke dass
die oma des immer darin macht er halt
kein programm hatte aber später lässt
sich dass das sehr leichter rausnehmen
wenn es im programm habt arbeit werde
ich erst mal die zwei zutaten zeigen für
den sirup nämlich zucker und wasser
zucker habe ich jetzt 200 gramm und
wasser 200 milliliter und jetzt nämlich
beide zutaten und normalerweise wird
einfach ein klasse start sogar sirup
gekocht das heißt zucker und wasser gern
reingeben in den topf von einfach
aufkochen lassen wenn ihr möchtet und es
geschmacklich so ein bisschen aufpimpen
wollt dann lasst doch zuerst den zucker
karamellisieren
mittel hohe hitze und schmeckt
karamellisieren lassen
normalerweise ruhig karamell nicht durch
und lass das mal komplett
karamellisieren ich will es jetzt aber
organe zu dunkel werden lassen weil das
einfach so schaus reicht der ganze zug
ist auch noch nicht komplett geschmolzen
macht aber nix ich lösch sind sowieso
mit wasser ab seit tagen bitte sehr
vorsichtig am besten kein eiskaltes
wasser ihr könnt auch gerne warmes oder
heißes wasser nimmt denn wenn jetzt
kaltes wasser hier rein gibt und der
zucker zu heiß ist kann es passieren
dass das ganze nach oben spritzt also
damit karamell immer bisschen vorsichtig
sein
und es ist auch ganz normal dass er
jetzt erst mal fest wird der karamell
als ein club aber der löst sich jetzt
praktisch mit dem zucker wieder auf und
dann habe ich nicht nur einen normalen
zucker sirup sondern eben eine karamell
zu passieren und dann schalte ich jetzt
wieder den herd hoch damit das wasser
eben auch kochen kann und sich der
zucker dann auflöst
[Musik]
jetzt komme ich denn sirup einfach so
lange bis sich der zucker komplett
aufgelöst hat und der ein bisschen
dickflüssig ist das dauert jetzt kurz
aber ich kann das hier schon mal kochen
lassen und so lange man zwieback
verteilen
nämlich hier einfach mein alublech weil
es ganz gut den kühlschrank passt denn
das dass er muss nicht gebacken werden
das ist ein kühlschrank des er also no
big sozusagen und dann hier den bug
rahmen drauf wunder kann ich hier mein
zwieback einfach schnell rein schichten
schön flächendeckend
[Musik]
jetzt ist ihr den sirup über die
zwieback teilchen drüber über den tiber
geschlagen ist der zwieback können sie
im löffel machen ich nehme es
tatsächlich einfach die dosis flasche
dann kann ich das ein bisschen besser
handhaben
und besseres mit und vor allem passen
die jetzt noch nicht ganz exakt rein
aber die weichen jetzt ein bisschen auf
und dann kann ich die noch ein bisschen
zurechtrücken
das ist schön damit trinken ich muss
aber sagen ich habe so ein bisschen den
zuckersirup reduziert und dritte weil
die oma der hat halt immer so drei bis
400 gramm dazu gegeben und drei wird das
fand ich schon deswegen habe ich gedacht
200 reicht aus den pudding da wird ja
auch
also ich jetzt darüber geben musst du
nur aufpassen dass ein bisschen bauen
[Musik]
anlass dieses ziel kurz stehen das kann
schon mal einziehen achtet darauf dass
der sirup nicht zu dickflüssig wird also
da muss schon west also nicht ganz
westrich aber so leicht an dicken damit
der zwieback das eben auch gut aufsaugen
kann das lasse ich wie gesagt hier
stehen den topf benutze ich gleich
weiter nicht auswaschen und zeigt euch
jetzt noch die zutaten für den pudding
der wirt nimmt jetzt nichts gebracht für
den pudding verwende ich einen liter
milch 80 gramm zucker etwas wandel
extrakt und 90 gramm stärke im
türkischen nennt man den pudding
übrigens einfach nur halb so heister
dort und es gebe ich erstmal die
trockenen zutaten in meinen top wie
gesagt dann nehm jetzt einfach den
ebenso hatte
[Musik]
da kommt da jetzt meinen vanille extract
dazu vergangene schön geschmack und ein
bisschen milch erstmal nur ein teil
damit ich nämlich die stärke schön glatt
werden kann
[Musik]
und dann einfach die restliche milch
statt zu giessen
ok hat auch einen größeren topf keine
kann
ich kriegte dahin nicht auch jetzt kurz
vor dem
überkochen
hier zeigt ganz gibt es da hätte ich
doch den murat stock nehmen hier
bald alles reingepackt
schafft das
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt gibt es wieder runter
gestellt
es kann becker
mehr glück als verstand
wie sollte ich kenne
ich hatte euch zu einem licht größten
tops
dann komme ich jetzt gerade so ein
bisschen das schön ein dicht und da
empfehle ich wirklich immer so einer
mitte hohe hitze damit der pudding am
topfboden nicht anbrennt bevor er
irgendwo auftaucht
das passiert nämlich gerne mal
eigentlich nur bei töpfen die die hitze
nicht so gut leiten aber bisher meist so
dass man einfach irgendwelche edelstahl
tag fördern so nimmt das kind übrigens
euro gusseisen benutzen zum kochen ich
habe da immer eine schöne gleichmäßige
verteilung aber ich finde so ein pudding
ist es immer gut mit seinem
stil ist die ordnerin schützen können
ich dachte jetzt kurz ein bisschen
kochen und entweder könnt ihr denn
direkt da reingeben oder ihr streicht
ihr noch durch ein feines haar sieht das
mache ich jetzt gleich weil sich doch
irgendwelche klümpchen mit drin hab mich
die später einfach nicht in meinem
interesse haben und ihr nehmt den wird
ein hase oder
das fleißige lieschen
das gleiche nämlich da einfach darüber
geben und natürlich da rein
[Musik]
so sieht der pudding jetzt aus und wie
gesagt jetzt einfach durch ein feines
sieb streichen und schön verteilen das
macht man jetzt tatsächlich noch wenn er
sehr warm ist denn dann verteilt er sich
gut und dann wird er auch schon fest in
der form so wie ich es brauche
schön verteilt was mache ich jetzt kurz
hier mit seiner tiefen winkel palette
und dann darf das ganze erstmal abkühlen
so lange kann ich die kokons hast du
eine frau bereits
[Musik]
zum fertig stellen nehme ich jetzt noch
100 gramm focus raspeln einen teelöffel
zimt 400 gramm sahne etwas vanille
extract sondersitzung steif schlagen und
wenn ihr möchtet gerne noch 30 partien
also eigentlich ist das hier fertig wenn
jetzt noch kokosraspeln drauf streut so
hat es meine heimat macht aber wie
gesagt aufgepumpt jetzt heute ich will
noch ein bisschen mehr geschmack
einbringen man muss auch sagen das ist
so nachtisch der einfach günstig ist
schnell gemacht ist eine große portion
man kann es toll vorbereiten im
kühlschrank lagern mehrere tage und
deswegen war das hat auch immer so ein
beliebtes rezept aber bindet es uns
bisschen verfeinern wollten ein bisschen
geschmacklich noch etwas aufpeppen
wollte dann weg sagt könnt ihr meine
version machen ich gebe jetzt die
kokosraspeln daher in eine pfanne denn
wenn man müsse kokosraspeln mandeln et
cetera riss dort bekommen sie einfach
mehr geschmack und ich gebe da sogar
noch ein bisschen zimt dazu denn zimt
passt auch perfekt zum kokos geschmack
ein bisschen rost ein bisschen leicht
farbe haben bisschen
während das hier raste kann ich schon
mal die sahne creme schlagen das heißt
sahne mit vanille extrakt und seine
fahrt einfach schlagen
autos richtung richtig lecker
[Musik]
jetzt nicolas sagen wird
jetzt fühle ich jetzt schon mal um damit
er schön abkühlen kann das brauch ich
nämlich später ganz kalt und sobald die
sahne steif geschlagen ist stilles firma
interstuhl schrank
stellen es mal weg form einer kalten
sahne dass die warm wird
[Musik]
jetzt ist der pudding komplett abgekühlt
und die sahne creme kann auf gestrichen
werden was sich da so wahnsinnig finde
ist in der türkei da gibt es auch keinen
sommer parteien sonst eigentlich gar
kein sachstand mittel weil die meist
immer creme shanti benutzen dass es so
zu einem schlag creme die kennt man hier
auch und wenn sie sahne benutzen also
krämer dann hat die sahne einfach so
viel fettanteil dass die sich halt immer
wunderbar aufschlagen lässt hier gibt es
auch richtig gute seine sorten muss ich
sagen und je mehr fettgehalt umso
schneller ist dann halt auch steif zu
bekommen deswegen ist dort immer ganz
praktisch aber ich glaub ich hab viele
zuschauer dort die sich dort auch die
sonne stand mittel wünschen weil ich das
eben immer in den rezepten benutze ich
glaube dir müssten das mal auf frisch
gefragt 10 niveau bekommen zu einer
party
und die meisten schmuggeln
sie einfach die creme schon verstreichen
und es können jetzt entweder ganz glatt
machen oder so ein bisschen wenig oder
gerne zwei karten für ein kleines die
muster
jedenfalls ist das jetzt einfach so noch
mal so eine auflockernde schicht weil
der pudding jedoch relativ
fest und
kompakt ist und die sahne diesen soften
locker
[Musik]
und jetzt schön abdecken und für
mindestens 4 stunden in den kühlschrank
stellen der norweger lacht dann habt ihr
einfach am nächsten tag ein tolles er
ich werde dazu später wahrscheinlich ein
paar früchte aufschneiden damit
dekorieren kann die pistazien noch
hacken und dann ist es wirklich ein
wunderschönes bisher wie von oben nur so
ein bisschen aufgepeppt
jetzt ist mein des akut durch gekühlt
wie gesagt wer sich jetzt noch die
pistazien haken die kommen noch darauf
verständigten bessere
einfach nur ganz grob hacken ich find
die passen geschmacklich ganz gut und
farblich aber auch ganz gut weil es
einfach immer so einen grünen touch mit
reinbringen und wenn ihr möchtet dann
könnt ihr da gerne wie gesagt auch
früchte mit anrichten müsst ihr aber
natürlich finde nur sie dann ganz schön
frisch aus und dann wertet das dass er
einfach noch mal auf dann hat man so aus
einem einfachen zwieback pudding dass er
einfach was schönes gezaubert
dann sehe ich das jetzt hier runter
und debug folie darunter weg die könnte
nämlich einschlagen und darunter
wegrollen
und wenn ihr das jetzt in einer
glasfaser habt dann könnt ihr direkt
alles in der glas verlassen schön
schneiden und dann rausheben aber so ist
eben der vorteil dass man nicht
rausheben muss weil man es eben gleich
unter der mit dem bug rahmen entfernen
kann das mich sind einfach
[Musik]
jetzt schneide ich schön gleichmäßiges
stücke zu recht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das lässt sich so jetzt übrigens
abgedeckt im kühlschrank mehrere tage
lagern und wenn ich dann serviert könnte
es gerne noch ein bisschen hübsch
anrichten also so ist es halt ganz
klassisch und einfach finde ich auch
sehr hübsch aber ihr könnt auch wie
gesagt gerne noch pistazien nehmen und
frische früchte und ich finde dann ist
es echt auch so optisch schönes
highlight und besagen dass er so ein
türkisches klassisches dessert was man
sich so vielleicht nicht vorstellen kann
wobei ich muss sagen zwieback und milch
oder zwieback und zu dieser pudding das
kind machen glaubt auch in der deutschen
küche und ich würde sagen ich lasse
jetzt utah mal gleich probieren was
passiert er dazu sagt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vier tage später schon weg die mutter
hat uns schon verlassen die kommt morgen
wieder aber ich habe mir gedacht ist
lars 12 fachmänner probieren die reinen
den murat unter anderem der gärtner des
vertrauens in zwei teams kurz meine
hände waschen grasen gedüngt mit pinguin
ja und das riecht nach
wir dann haben wir hier gerne wenn es
genau dennis muss in unserer mitte ach
so denn
so ganz kurze vorstellung zu dennis er
hat schon zwei sterne erkocht also
wirklich ein ganz junger talentierter
koch darf man noch jung sagen mit 28 ja
genau aber filmen sind zwei mal
einstellen ok alles ist an zwei stellen
ja genau so auf jeden fall wir haben ein
sternekoch und dennis bei uns im team
mit dem wir haben wir gerade in
entwicklungen projekte die man zusammen
machen wir dürfen nicht sagen was
natürlich jetzt steht dann sternekoch
und ich habe die bank deshalb gemacht
und die pizzen läuft ja ja mein papa hat
immer zwei bis fünfzehn frühstück und
das kind habe ich immer so weiter kein
ebook mit dem namen und sind nicht ganz
wahr bekommen wird nicht gedealt hat
freund schon sechs fifa gestern
krankheit stinkt ja wenn man so wissel
magen und
ich stehe gerade als ritter kühle wagen
vorbeifahren mir vor leid mich sehr auch
voll schlimm aus es tut mir wirklich
leid aber ich war gerade am rasen
dringen bis ich den anruf bekommen haben
probieren und dann hat er gesagt passt
dreht ihr noch dann habe ich die sonne
geht unter wir drehen immer noch wir
sind fleißig
und das ding ist es sich auch noch
veganer dünger verstoßen ich meine darf
eigentlich gar nicht stinken der ist das
egal doch der schwägerin
es ist nein er ist wirklich veganer ding
ich weiß aber nicht warum ich nach
gagarin keine ahnung wie wir diese hatte
bedenken dass wir angesichts
ok probiert mal gern also das ist eines
meiner oma immer gemacht hat es nennt
sich zwieback desserts wie bagdad musste
gab es ist bei euch auch nehmen weil er
dann haben mich gepackt weil backen war
was für
wir haben kein geld
und der torwart erkennt dass auch und in
der türkei heißt es in dem actros also
es wird aus altem brot eigentlich
gemacht hat schon so günstig ist dass
ich habe ein bisschen aufgepeppt mit so
sind kokosflocken oder medizin schmeißt
man sagt auch in der sterneküche immer
auch himbeeren auf und immer diese
komischen macht und warum machen wir das
ich habe ein
ich habe ein türkisches moharebeh mit
geschlagener sahne auf
karamellisiertem
zwieback
mit
gerösteten im zimt gewalzten
kokosflocken mit einem fruchtig und ich
hab ja verboten aber wieso machen wir
das eigentlich
mittlerweile schreibt eine speisekarte
einfach nur
was ich gar nicht kann ist das
schweinchen oder schiffchen den stäbchen
anhöre dann
truppe durchaus üblichen drehte dagegen
wenn unsere expressen einer
espressotasse folgen dann ist schon
super
[Musik]
kombi hat der beruf macht mir zuerst
hatte ich probleme ob es schmeckt
jetzt kommen du kannst ihn werde ich
weiß nicht ob ich noch nie gemacht
tatsächlich es hat immer ein
riesen stück
er ist süß
es gibt eine kugel eis für alle
stefan aus rockenhausen ruft wegen der
küche
nächsten ticks summiert auch zu sich so
anders war aber etwas milder spannung
und das meine ich
habe jetzt ein bisschen knapp gerechnet
so umwelt zwieback und
dann hast du ein gewisses tränken mit
dem zur regierung genau deswegen ist
nicht super lecker und
dicken turm gut ich denke dass die aber
ich hab's ich muss gestehen ich habe
vorher noch ein bisschen sehr gut drauf
gegeben weil ich ein paar stellen der
stadt das heißt wenn ihr so wie es ein
rezept steht macht dann passt es mit der
süwag
okay und ich glaube das ist halt auch
einfach so ein ding mal meine oma hatte
sich immer für europa gemacht und das
war kein knapp drin damit die das hat
auch mit ihrem dritten essen kann
das ist was für ältere leute
ja nur holen irgendwann ramadan hat auch
perfekt weil du kannst halt direkt zum
blech voll machen habe ich im
kühlschrank mehrere tage lagern immer
ganz wichtig und dann in kleinen station
ins all ihren tisch ist ein cooles
kanada dritte genau gemacht genau okay
ich gehe weiter
nein nein nein - sagen wir dürfen nicht
sagen was du gemacht aber es ist eben
ein konzept auf zeit.de oder in meiner
ecke und ich freue mich auf euer
feedback vielleicht gab es dass das sehr
oder gibts muss er auch bei euch zu
hause vielleicht kennt es aus der
kindheit oder aus dem türkei urlaub
schreibt es mir ganz gerne und schreibt
mir auch gerne mal was bei euch zu hause
so das typische oma rezeptor
bei dir menschen ältere ja ich glaub ich
kannte man muss ehrlich sagen ja kannst
du kannst schon immer noch kann ich nur
oh ja eine oma kannte ich die anderen
schneider schon vorher verstorben
das nächste mal mache ich mich
sterneköche
[Musik]